i internalize this idea that unless i
get a hundred percent unless i win
i'm not good enough i'm not loved doctor
and broadcaster doctor wrong and
chatterjee your first book was a huge
success my guest today is the perfect
guest it's a really big honor to have
you on my podcast
my son janam getting sick at six months
old changed the course of my career you
see we need to evolve the way that we
practice medicine sleep deprivation is
associated with pretty much every single
chronic disease we have compared to
about 60 years ago we may have lost up
to 25 of our sleep the way
society is set up now is making us
lonely we've moved away for work we've
moved away from our families we don't
have the tribes around us and it's very
very damaging for our health it took me
ages to figure this out the dots i think
you can always make a change right you
can use these
moments of diversity in your life to
teach you something it's the best
journey you'll ever take but it's a
journey it's not a one hit
the first step in any change is
so without further ado
i'm stephen butler and this is the diary
of a ceo i hope nobody's listening but
if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
dr rongan chatterjee
i am i have to say i have to stop this
conversation by saying it's a really big
honor to have you on my podcast because
you are someone when i started taking my
podcast seriously who i looked up to and
admired for so many reasons not because
you are you've really kind of paved the
way for these long-form conversations in
the uk
but because you have the same very
similar subject matter and apparent
interest in the conversations you have
with your guests to the point that it
inspired me in a really big way to start
this platform and so when um when i
found out that you were coming in today
it felt like you know it felt like a bit
of a felt like christmas day for me
because the the conversations you have
are the things that i
would spend my spare time
sort of um watering my brain with so
thank you first and foremost for coming
in today it's a huge huge privilege i
receive and i appreciate you saying that
and and likewise i feel really honoured
and excited to come on your show because
i think long-form conversation matters
and i don't there's that many people in
the uk
doing it like you are like i am and um
you know i think you're doing great
things with your shows so i'm i'm i'm
really excited just to have a long
conversation with you i don't know where
it's going to go
but um yeah thanks for having me so take
me back to the foundations who who were
you
so i grew up in the northwest of england
and
you know mum and dad were immigrants
from india you know dad came over in
1962 for a better life to the uk mum
came over in 1972 i grew up got an older
brother
and
you know like many immigrant families
education was
king
right it was about get good grades at
school go to a good university get a
good job
right that was the
kind of drive from home my experience
was very much
man the culture at school was really
different from the culture at home
and i didn't really think much of it at
the time but you know now in my early
40s looking back and reflecting as i've
done
for this new book is
that was incredibly problematic
in many ways because
you end up pretending
to be somebody you're not
in order to fit in
and i can see now that's been a pattern
for most of my life i've not been myself
i've tried to be someone else i've
i've tried to
do things to get validation and love
from other people and
i've got to say it's only been in the
last years where i've managed to kind of
let that go
another piece there which i think is
really relevant to your question is
because education was such
a big thing
you know because mum and dad dad in
particular so much discrimination he
faced
right when he came here in his job he
had to change career change speciality
as a doctor because he just couldn't
advance and so ultimately he ended up
moving to a speciality he didn't like he
didn't enjoy
to give his family security
so what do they want to do they want
their children to not have to go through
that
so
i grew up with this kind of idea that
i'm only loved
when i'm top of the class right i'd come
home if i got 99 in an exam my mum would
say why didn't you get 100.
what if i came out
uh with 19 out of 20 in a test okay what
happened why didn't you get 20.
now what's really interesting about that
is i'm not criticizing my parents right
i love my parents i think they've
brought me up really well
but it but it speaks to a situation
there's different perceptions right so
i spoke to mum recently i said hey mom
why
why did you ask me those questions you
know why did you push me so hard
and she said to me because i knew you
were capable i wanted you to be the best
that you could be
so mom did it with me from a place of
love right she wanted the best for me
but walk around to the other side of
that story i internalize this idea that
unless i get 100
unless i win
i'm not good enough i'm not loved
and i can now see that drove me my
entire life this need for
external validation what are other
people saying about you people say nice
things you feel good people say nasty
things you are literally broken inside
so
you know a lot there that i've come to
terms with over the past few years but
for me understanding that i can go back
and rewrite those stories put a
different
perspective on all those events
has given me this real sense of freedom
calm contentness
and ultimately
you know it's resulted in me feeling
really really happy
one of the things you
you've said is that
you believe the purpose of life is
really finding out who you are because
once you find out who you are then you
can go on the journey of finding out
what is what it is you want so my
question for you is
what did you then pursue as a
consequence of believing that external
validation was
true validation that was true truly your
purpose what was your
how were you misguided or led astray
yeah so i went to
university at edinburgh at edinburgh
medical school you know left home having
the time of my life partying you know
whatever you know people when they they
get that sort of sense of freedom for
the first time
a lot of my uni life was spent playing
in bands right so music is a big part of
who i am what i do
um you know so i'd be practicing layers
we'll be playing loads and loads of gigs
and then it all changed i must have been
20 21.
i think mum phoned me at like 10 30 at
night and said hey look dad's in
intensive care the doctors don't think
he's gonna
make it through the nights can you come
back home and i remember seeing dads in
the incentive care unit and you know he
ended up surviving the nights
his kidneys failed he went on kidney
dialysis for the next 15 years but
basically
dad getting ill changed
the trajectory of my adult life so yes i
was in edinburgh i finished off i worked
there for a couple of years but my mind
was always back in the northwest
and i moved back to the northwest which
is one of the reasons i live there now
to help my mum and my brother look after
dad and it was incredibly stressful
particularly in the last years before
dad i had really really stressful and i
would i would escape periodically so
coming back to your question about how
does that impacted me i wanted to do
well like i got my specialist exams i
uh want i got good jobs in prestigious
hospitals right i got those things i
thought that's what i'm doing i'm doing
the right thing
and then when dad died in 2013 march
2013
it was like there was a big hole in my
life and so
i would just go walking
i was just trying to make sense of
everything and the truth is the amount i
learnt from dad's death
was just profound i'm not sure i would
have learned these things i was asking
myself whose life are you really leading
i don't regret any of it
now that dad's not here i'm glad i spent
so much time with him
but i think it was a real cost to me
my inner peace my inner well-being
and dad's death here's the irony stephen
the things that my dad would have been
proudest of right
indian immigrant to the uk his son with
his own bbc one show in 2015 2016 right
his son with four sunday times
bestsellers dad would have
literally
been phoning all the relatives you know
being the embarrassing dad telling
everyone dad never got to see any of it
but i know if that was still alive
i'd be doing none of it
why
if i was still in the mindset that i was
when my dad was sick
i wouldn't have any time to engage in
this stuff like life
if there's anyone listening to this
who's a carer for someone in their life
they'll know what i'm talking about you
you don't have time you don't have
physical time you don't have mental
space
it just
it encompasses the entirety of your life
you're just trying to keep your head
above water you're just
trying to
get through day to day
you are fire fighting so i wouldn't have
had the
the physical time but also
i think a lot of what i'm able to give
to people these days
through books through podcasts through
you know one-on-one with patients
is the learnings you know that the
learnings i've acquired
from going through dad's death from
going through that pain from coming out
the other side from going what can i
learn from this
so
i'm not sure
if what i would have had to offer people
back then would have been
as valuable as what i feel i have to
offer them now
why did you choose medicine was that
again part of this broader thing of
thinking that was success and that would
be
that would satisfy parents or you know
society because again there's a bit of a
stereotype isn't there there with a
indian immigrant coming over and you
know when i sit here with um people from
that that background typically the
narrative is and to be fair in my case
as well as an african immigrant that
successes doctor lawyer
etc
100
you know
it is a stereotype but but it's largely
true for many families you know
as an indian immigrants child in the uk
the three careers that generally are
available to you are dots a lawyer
engineer
that's what is valued
of course just to be clear that's not
every single family but just by and
large
i think that's true
but i tell you this stephen i know loads
of them who are so unhappy as doctors
so unhappy they compensate for the
tedium of their work
right by getting smashed on a friday and
saturday nights
right and they wonder why they can't
give up boozing or why they enjoy it so
much well because that's a symptom
it's not the drinking isn't the problem
the drinking is a symptom
you don't enjoy your job
you've gone into the wrong career
because you thought it was what you
should do sometimes you're stuck now in
your 30s you've got a mortgage
you know you've got
a lease on your car you feel trapped
but you can free yourself from that trap
you you absolutely can but you have to
be honest you have to get to know who
you currently are now
before you've got any hope
of becoming the person that you i didn't
want to be
it's so unbelievably true in every way i
mean so much of that i can relate to for
so many reasons and
you know you were talking there about
your your almost your parents missed
place love what you've clearly managed
to figure out later in your life is that
actually came from a place of love yeah
that's why i call it misplaced love
because they were trying to protect you
because they loved you
but it turns out that
that
misplaced love what it's doing is it's
stopping you from being your truest self
and the long term consequences of that
when you end up living someone else's
life is what you've spoken to there the
symptoms of
addiction and drinking and impulsive
behavior that we see in people so my
overall conclusion there was this urgent
need as soon as possible in your life to
get in touch with exactly who you are
and defend it at all costs
at all if you can do it at 16 if you're
45 and listening to this
now is the the second best time yeah i
mean
i've got so much to say on that um
you're never too late
to start on this journey
but how does someone start on that
journey right
i think it comes down to
values
right
values is what
i think what sews it all up together
right so
you know for this new book i've created
this new model of happiness i call core
happiness
so core happiness has three components
alignment contentment and control we can
talk about those if you want
but one of those legs is alignment
alignment is when
your
inner values and your external actions
are the same when the person who you
want to be inside and the person you are
actually being in the world are one and
the same that's one component it's not
everything but it's one component
so if someone has heard what we're
talking about say okay i want to start
i'm not living the life that i want to
lead but i don't know where to start
there's this exercise in the book called
the identity menu and the goal is really
that you
go through and i picked number three
because i think it's quite a um a
realistic number for people out of the
list of all these possible identities
and values
which three do you think
feel
kind of the most true to you and i've
been doing this for a little while and
the three that have been pretty static
with me for the past few months now i'd
say and they're right at the top of my
instagram profile because i think this
is what i want to give to the world and
say let's
lead with our values
integrity curiosity and compassion
so this is who i am
right i'm not
a doctor i'm not a father
now i i really i think this is such an
important point that i've been thinking
a lot about the last few years
i have a role as a doctor i have a role
as a father but it's not who i am
because when we cling too tightly to our
identities
we put ourselves in a very fragile
position let's say
you know i go over i'm the doctor you
know i'm dr chatterjee you know when i i
sort of absorb that and i think that's
who i am then what happens
if i get fired
right what happens if i get sick and i
can't work as a doctor what happens when
i retire this this is real this happens
to people they lose their sense of who
they are
what about my role as a father
right
to be really clear
me bringing up my kids well is one of
the most important things to me more
important than my work 100
but being a good father is not who i am
if i cling too tightly to that what
happens
when my kids are teenagers
and they get annoyed and they call me a
crap dad
i've seen this happen i've had patients
come in
say oh they call me a crap mom but you
know that's all i do i i do everything
for them i've given everything up for
them it's like wait a minute
you are much more than your roles
you know let's talk about cars right
you said when you were 20 you wrote down
what you wanted right
there's nothing wrong with having a nice
car
the problem comes for your happiness at
least
when you identify
with that car where that car says
something about you and the problem is
you drive around i don't mean you one
drives around in their flash
bmw let's say
and they think you know that says
something about me who i am what i'm
saying if you lose your job what happens
if you prang it what happens if you have
a divorce and you can't afford it
anymore
you go from what i call core happiness
to junk happiness junk happiness is what
many of us think happiness is
right we think it's that momentary hit
of pleasure
you know buying something online
instagram uh chocolate bar uh hit of
booze right these things can be
pleasurable things they may have their
role from time to time but don't mistake
that for being
real core happiness
core happiness is i think what we are
chasing but i think we misdefine it we
think it's something it's not happiness
it's not a destination that we one day
get to right it's a direction that you
can choose to take in life it's a choice
right
i heard your conversation with mo in the
hotel room last night which was
fantastic so good
and i agree with what you and me was
saying happiness is a choice
when you understand what happiness
really is what is it
it's not a thing
that you can get to
it's not something that you can
pursue directly it's something that
ensues when you do
the right things
and the right things for me
are when you focus on the three
i call call happiness this three-legged
stool alignment contentment control you
can apply it to anything in life i i
think that's what happiness is and i
think we are pursuing it like people say
we shouldn't be
we shouldn't be going after happiness we
should be going after meaning have you
heard that yeah yeah all the time right
i have a different perspective
meaning and purpose
is really important no question
but i don't think that's happiness it's
meaning
right
it's a necessary ingredient
for happiness but it's not happiness in
and of itself and i don't mean to be
controversial but let's say
um
a soldier fighting in world war ii
against the nazis
right
one might make the case that
that has meaning
it doesn't mean they're happy hundred
percent right so meeting hummus is
subtly different have you heard of the
japanese concept of ikigai yes yeah yeah
right i love ikigai this idea that
um
you know we should be looking we not
should be but we could be looking for
something in our life that we enjoy
that we're good at
that's what the world needs
and what pays us money
right the kind of holy grail does it
were and i remember writing about this
in my second book on stress i remember
the book came out and i was in london i
was giving
a talk
and at the end of the talk we were doing
q and a
i remember the back right of the hall
this young lady had a hand up and she
said dr shastaji
i'm an 18 year old japanese student
living in london
i've grown up with the concept of ikigai
my entire life and frankly i found it
demoralizing demotivating too high a bar
for me to get to
and that stuck with me mate because i
thought since then okay that's so
interesting because i love this concept
of icky guy
she grows up with it and finds it
off-putting
i think the problem with
these grand ideas of meaning purpose
ikigai
as much as i like them
they're not for everyone someone someone
might be hearing that in a call center
right now they don't like their job
they're doing it and they're like what
icky guy you're kidding me mate i just
want to get through and and pay the
bills right so i think i bring it all
back is this core happiness store that
i've created is it applicable in all
situations i think it is because if you
look at it through the lens of what
we're talking about this comes under
alignment
so that chat working in the call center
they do the exercise and they figure out
kindness is something that's really
important to them
then
if on the way to work
they stop in the coffee shop and they're
kind to the barista
they get on the bus to work and they're
kind to the bus driver they go to the
job they don't particularly like but
they are kind to their colleagues and
their boss
they're living an aligned life they're
living with meaning it doesn't mean that
the job that they're in currently is the
job that they love and they're going to
be in forever but they're living in
harmony with who they are and that's
going to mean that meaning and purpose
come naturally as a byproduct
so i want people to really focus on
alignment
it's one pillar of happiness and i think
your meaning and purpose will come can
you talk to me about control as well
i thought long and hard about this word
control
and i am denied was it the right word to
use and i spoke to some of my patients i
suspect some of my friends
i don't really think it is when we
understand it's about what are the
things that i can do
in my life that gives me a sense of
control we know from the scientific
research when you have a sense of
control
right you have better relationships you
have longer relationships you're
healthier you have lower stress levels
you live longer
so it's that sense of control and and
that could mean many things to to
different people you know for me
i'm really big on morning routines right
i know for me if i get up early if i
have time to myself to have a little
routine
i've i've almost got this like resilient
bubble around me doesn't matter what's
going on in the world doesn't matter how
bad work may or or may not get that day
i've got an element of control because
i've i've sort of nurtured that routine
for myself so that's one that's one way
that people can think about control and
another way people might want to think
about control is
there's a and there's a chapter in the
book called talk to strangers
which is basically this idea that
actually
relationships are very important of
course but there's kind of two different
kinds of relationships that are the deep
nurturing intimate relationships but
there's also the
there's also those kind of
almost trivial interactions that we have
day to day
right so when you say hi to the barista
or you know i said hi to your work
colleagues when i got here
those little things
they are not trivial there's a network
in your brain called the sociometer
right it's constantly detecting
your external world for threats and when
it receives positive information like a
smile like a you know a bit of a nod a
handshake
you know it it sort of relaxes you your
stress levels go down you feel a sense
of connection with the world around you
coming back to control
you feel that the external world is safe
i've got degree of control there is
order in the world let's focus
on these simple things you can do each
day if you
say hi to the amazon delivery driver and
smile at them say thank you to the
barista and say a few nice words to them
say hi to the bus driver and smile at
them thank the postmen
you are working on your happiness
you know it seems trivial but it's not
the research is so so clear right
because it gives you a sense of control
second pillar of the three
and we've got to touch on the third
pillar before i start getting into all
of these topics because so it's so
interesting that these are the things
that you know we're talking about today
because i think i spent all weekend
um reading about studies on the
importance of you call it the sociometer
in the brain but just that that thing
that connects you with
your tribe but please do get into the
third point which i think you said was
contentment contentment yeah yeah
contentment is
about feeling calm and that sense of
peace when you're at peace with your
life and you're at peace with your
decisions so what things in your life
give you that sense of contentment
and i really feel it's these three
things
when you put them all together
the side effect of doing them
is you're happy yeah right but but also
happiness is not
often what we think it is that that big
billboard image of the
the happy family on the beach with a
smile on their face in the ocean behind
them right
that to me
is not happiness that's a pleasurable
experience yeah it can form part of a
happy life
but that's not happiness you can be sad
and happy
the way i look at happiness core
happiness
i was thinking about this last week i
was chatting to someone who
who was going through grief
you know someone very close to them had
died
and you know we were having a really
long deep conversation
but they were present with their grief
and they were able to share with me
exactly how they were feeling no masks
on at all in terms of these kind of
metaphorical masks that we put on
they were just being themselves
that's called happiness
because they're aligned
right their inner thoughts are i feel
sad upset
frustrated for my loss
and their external actions
are completely aligned with that
so i kind of feel
really what happiness is about
is living an intentional life
it's about taking the time to understand
who you are
defining for yourself what happiness is
or what success looks like not using
society's definition you post a few days
ago don't use society's definition of
fun
right that's a great post you know just
because society says to have fun you
need to go to a bar have loud music on
and get drunk well if you like to sit at
home in the bath reading a good book
that that's great if you don't that's
fine as well but it's got to be you it's
your values so
i can't tell someone what they need to
necessarily do in all aspects of their
life to be happy
but be intentional about your life
my girlfriend came upstairs yesterday
when i was having a shower and she said
to me that she tried the heel protein
shake which lives on my fridge over
there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
in the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein
if you haven't tried the cured protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
you know when people give um advice in
their books and you know when i do it
online with my content there's something
which i
realize
has to be done first so as much as you
could have told me to get into alignment
the the counter force that was saying
[ __ ] that was this deep sense of
insecurity and that piece of work i had
to do as you describe it to heal first
before i could start looking with a
clear view
at um the way i was living my life
because if you'd asked steve butler at
18 years old what his values were
you know he would have said lamborghini
next question he would have said money
right i know there's not even values but
that's what he would have said right so
i'm interested to know how you think
someone can go on the journey of healing
um and understanding themselves in
self-awareness which i think is the
foundation and all the pillars you
mentioned of happiness
it's a great question um
i don't think it's going to be
you listen to this
conversation you watch it on youtube you
get the book whatever i don't think it's
that you do that and then you're like oh
i've got it i've figured it out now i
know my values okay great no this is a
journey
it's the best journey you'll ever take
but it's a journey it's not a one hit
the first step in any change
is awareness
all behaviors serve and needs
where every behavior we have is there
for a reason
you can't just i can't tell the patient
you should drink less alcohol
without helping them understand
why do they need to be drinking that
alcohol in the first place
right it took me ages to to figure this
out the dots i think why why why am i
struggling why do they stop for two
weeks then they they get back on the
horse it's like
oh we've not dealt with the underlying
needs it's like new year's resolutions
right
no one has a problem going spinning four
times a week for the first two weeks in
january
but third week fourth week
when life gets busy and life gets
stressed or they can give up booze for a
couple of weeks
and they just can't keep it going it's
like you know i need it to unwind from
my work day that's because your alcohol
consumption
is a symptom
of the way you're living your life if
you want to change that you can try and
white knuckle it and reduce it
sure you might be successful for a short
period of time but you'll always go back
unless you
understand the behavior
same thing kind of works for food
cravings a lot of the time so someone's
listening to this and they go okay i
want to know what to do
but even if they're starting to
challenge themselves already and go
you know i'm pretty interested what
these two guys are saying you know i
don't kind of know what my values are
but
i've got a feeling that i'm not living
life in accordance with them like i
think i'm chasing the wrong stuff but i
don't quite know what to do about that
even that awareness is progress
right so i think it's really important
we we can't always just find out get to
the solution go and live happy lives it
doesn't work like that
so step one is awareness now if you have
that awareness
and you want to go further
a simple thing you might want to do is
what i call the identity menu in the
book you might literally want to
try and write down three values or even
one value start with one right start
with one right just write down one value
and then
in a week's time ask yourself how often
in that week did you live in accordance
with that how often in that week did you
live
in a way that was not in harmony with
that okay it's not about beating
yourself up it's not about holding
yourself to this
unattainable ideal it's just ask
yourself the question just gently start
compassionately probing
what's going on
right so i think that's a useful
exercise and build up to three values if
you can
and you know these things need
reassessing the other exercise i like
which i think is really practical
it's got two parts it's called define
your happiness habits
and write your happy ending right and if
if you want we could try actually just
do it if you're right for us
so i would ask you stephen
think of three things
that really bring you a sense of
happiness deep calm and contentment and
make you really feel good
um
so i think one of them which i've
actually read about in your book is
about
serving others and helping others
it feels to me like a
a happiness rush or a sense of
fulfillment or contentment that i can't
seem to get anywhere else the other one
is like pursuing my artistic interests
so things like when i can see my djing
equipment over in the corner there when
i do my djing or when i give give time
to myself to write or create okay i call
that like expression that's like yeah um
and then i think the third one is is
what i think you call in your book like
movement
so moving so um
exercise when i go to the gym and i and
i'm not sure why that is because this
might fit into a number of categories
because in in part it's like meditative
when i'm on the running machine or on
the peloton it's really meditative on
the other part it's has there's
obviously physiological impacts and
biological impacts of the exercise and
then on the third part it might just be
because i'm giving time to myself so i'd
say those are the three that came to
mind straight away yeah okay so you've
you've picked what i call three
happiness habits yeah right so each week
and please correct me if i've
misinterpreted any of this
um each week if you could do something
that serves others
if you could engage in your artistic um
passions
and you could do a form of movement you
enjoy yeah there are three things that
would give you you know real sense of
happiness so i believe
okay no no i i think they probably are
and i'll share my name it's just second
seconds let's get to the second part of
the exercise
okay it's called write your happy ending
so
imagine now you're on your deathbed yeah
okay so at the end of this is it right
look back on your life
what are three things you will want to
have done so that's really interesting
because it's funny because the answers
are different
um one of them is definitely about
connecting with others my friends so
like my friends my family my niece
that's like that's in fact so central to
my happiness
um the third is helping others that
gives me a real sense of um that i spent
my time in a worthwhile way
and
sorry the second and the third would be
the third is a as a personal one it's
the feeling that i've i've
done my potential
justice yeah lived up to your potential
lived up to my potential done myself
justice yeah yeah
i love them i mean first of all thanks
for sharing that
um
so what's really interesting when you do
the second part now
you can go back
and redo the first one and
what's really beautiful i think there's
i think there's a real deceptive
simplicity
with this exercise it gives you the sort
of granular
day-to-day
look at your life and happiness and it
gives you the 30 000 foot kind of big
picture view and you can see if they're
aligned so if you do the three happiness
habits each week doing something for
someone else
sorry serving others
engaging creatively
and um
uh you know moving
will that get you to your happy ending
no
so i was missing one you're missing one
yeah the relationship piece yeah exactly
yeah and so this is not about catching
anyone out this is something i think we
can all benefit from myself including on
a regular basis
it doesn't mean you can automatically
change the entire trajectory of your
life but it does mean this is about
intention right it's like if that's what
the goal is at the end
well like for me
i know
three happiness habits for me are what
number one spending undistracted time
with my wife and my children each week
that's really important
number two doing something that helps
improve the health and well-being of
others
really important number three
having time
to pursue things that i'm passionate
about that's kind of my three
i'm doing the the
the final piece the 30 000 foot yeah so
i know
each week then for happiness habits if i
have let's say five meals
around the dinner table with my wife and
kids
that's
where there's no phones and we're
totally undistracted and in the moment
right i know that i'm i'm doing that
i know if i record an episode of my
podcast each week i know that i'm doing
something that's going to improve the
lives of other people
and if i have time to
i don't know play guitar play snooker um
you know whatever you know i've got all
kinds of creative passions
each week then i know that if i just
consistently do that just a little bit
each week i'm getting to the happy
ending that i want
and for that person who may be listening
to this and struggling that may be
something else that they can start doing
you know and what's really interesting
stephen is we think we think we're all
quite different there was a study from
last year which showed us that actually
despite all our differences we feel as
if we're being our true authentic selves
when we're being kind
compassionate
doing things for others enthusiastic
presence and in the moment right all of
us and what i love about these exercises
they really bring awareness and
attention to your life you could say
yeah i really value health i really
value my health and well-being and then
they can assess their life and go i do
nothing each week to support that i say
that's who i am but i'm not
you can say as i did for many years i
valued my friends you know what i got so
busy with work i wasn't making time to
see them
and again it's not about beating
yourself up this is really really
important point this is about honesty
and awareness right you're never going
to become the person who you want to be
until you know who is the person you are
right now it's not about guilt it's not
about shame it's about just transparency
going okay all right i'm not aligned at
the moment okay fine no problem i'm
going to take one step this week i'm
going to
make an effort once a week i'm going to
phone one of my best mates just for 10
minutes
just to say hi
even that
is
it's helping you become more aligned
it's helping you get to that happy
ending so
you know maybe there's some useful stuff
in there for people to kind of take and
actually start applying it's so funny
because when you said that exercise
you know i could spend a lot of time as
i think i have in the past trying to
figure out who i was and the techniques
are complicated and they're largely
influenced by um
who society thinks i should be and what
my values are the minute i did that
exercise it was so clear
it was so unbelievably easy to do and so
clear and then as you said when we
zoomed out to my deathbed and said like
what are the things in your last days
that you're going to value
to to see how obvious it was that i'd
left out something so
so so fundamentally important which is
like my friends my family my
relationships
in my sort of you know the things that
make me happy was like alarming to me it
was like how are you not
living in alignment mentally how how did
you not know that that was so
fundamental
i think you just beautifully illustrate
seeing that we can see it yeah
brilliantly in other people oh hundred
percent man i could see and you i could
see it in my patients but you know what
it's pretty hard sometimes to put the
mirror up and see it in yourself
do you know what i mean
i think the other you know i think you
you've asked a brilliant question what
can that person do
i think the other the other thing
and probably
arguably the biggest this is the biggest
thing i think that's had the most impact
on my happiness and wider health over
the past years
is this understanding
of perspective
that there are multiple perspectives
on the same situation and i think it's a
really important point for people to get
so let's say someone's stuck in their
life
i think look i don't know what to do i'm
trapped here right uh i i don't know i
get up i go to work you know i try and
look after my family you know i don't
know this stuff about values and all
that kind of stuff okay fine
if you just forget all that stuff for a
moment and go okay let me just see if i
can start broadening my perspective
because once you start broadening your
perspective and start seeing things from
somebody else's perspective it changes
everything so one of the ways i do this
is to understand that
this phrase
yeah i'll go as far as this
this phrase has had the most impact on
my health and happiness above anything
else
if i was the other person
i would be doing exactly the same as
them
again a very simple phrase but when you
really really get it you're basically
saying if i was that person
with their childhood
their
parents
with their life experiences
i would be acting in exactly the same
way as them
and if you think you wouldn't i would i
would
very gently invite you to consider that
this may be your ego talking
if they could act differently they would
and what that does is it brings such a
deep sense of compassion to every single
day of your life you can start to have a
perspective for them for example it
could be maybe their daughter was sick
last night and up and they didn't get
much sleep maybe they think they're
going to lose their job when they're
they're late for work right whatever it
is it doesn't matter the truth doesn't
matter right for your happiness the
truth i would say doesn't matter
again i don't mean to be controversial
but i think some people will take that i
think that's quite controversial you're
a football fan right there was a study
done
football match one incident
right um two sets of fans they were
interviewed about the incidents
both of them
had a completely different perspective
on the same incident
right you we all know that there's a
foul or you know one team that's
definitely foul that's a foul and a
yellow card the other side that was
nothing you didn't touch him he died we
know that anyone who's got a partner
right or had a partner
you have a row you have a disagreement
well depending on which side at the
table you're sitting on you have a
completely different perspective of the
same situation
right so i say in any situation choose a
happiness story
right i'll give you another example
one of the most profound conversations i
have ever had on my podcast was with
this lady called edith eager
when i spoke to her last year she was 93
years old
at the age of 16
she was getting ready that evening she
had a date with her boyfriends
knock on the door
her parents her and her sister get put
on a train taken to auschwitz
within a couple of hours of getting
there
edith's parents get murdered
somehow she gets through
the next few years she survives what she
has taught me
is that
you can always create a different story
on any single event
she said when she was in auschwitz she
was totally free
the prisoners they were free
they were the ones who won't be able to
act and behave the way that they wanted
to they were trapped in her mind she was
free
after her parents had died she had to
dance for the guards
right
and she said the last thing my mom said
to me
was edith nobody can ever take away from
you what you put inside your mind
so she's dancing there she knows her
parents are dead but in her mind
she said
wrong and i was dancing in budapest
opera house
there was a full orchestra there's full
crowds i was dancing there
right the other thing she said to me
is i've been in auschwitz but i can tell
you the greatest prison
you will ever live in is the prison you
create inside your minds
so
for people who are listening who
struggle to forgive
who struggle to see the other side who
see someone
put a tweet up and then spend an hour
getting agitated and frustrated
i
humbly
suggest to you if edith eager can write
a different story
in the hell of auschwitz
i kind of feel
we probably can as well
it's so true that
the greatest harm we cause to ourselves
is is our own
negative or illogical or
self-harming stories as you were saying
that i was thinking about even the
stories i've i've told myself in the
last 24 hours or the last week which
have like tormented me mentally in the
sense of they've just like bothered me
unnecessarily and how much of a choice
it was for me to focus on those stories
if you know what i mean like
as you say like someone tweeting
something or leaving a comment and then
that you then give
48 hours of your happiness to just this
when you could as you've expressed so
eloquently choose compassion for the
person and
you know you could you could choose to
try and find the best intentions in any
behavior right yeah
the way i i put it in the book there's a
little section called make everyone a
hero
i think it's such a great sentiment in
life whenever something happens you
don't like make them a hero
make them a hero i challenge people try
that for seven days if your life has not
been improved in any way fine forget it
say the guy was splashing nonsense i'm
not interested i'm getting back to my
cynical nature i'm gonna see the worst
in everyone right fine
it's up to people make them a hero the
person who cuts you up find a way to
make them a hero in your heads
right
march 2020 what happened
everything's getting locked down
toilet roll shortage on the shelves
right so what do people do now i
understand that was a very unique
situation people are getting triggered
people are getting scared i understand
that but let's look at what was
happening
people were bad mouthing um who are
these people who are taking all these
toilet rolls it's so inconsiderate you
know they shouldn't be doing that okay
okay fine
let's just see could we write a
different story what might have happened
well it could be that every shopper that
day
took one extra roll and so by the end of
the day when the tv cameras came in
no one actually did anything that bad
they just took one extra roll
and the supermarket stock was all
planned around
average
shopping habits and behaviors okay
um it could be
that someone was really really scared
and anxious and let's say they've got
ulcerative colitis and they have to go
to the toilet 20 times a day and they're
petrified so maybe they did go and buy
ten packs or maybe let's take it to
another extreme maybe
someone is skint
right they've got no money they've got
no prospects in life they thought you
know what i can make a fortune here
right so i'm gonna get them all i'm
gonna sell them on ebay okay
whatever you think
of that if you can have compassion for
that person and understand if i was them
i'd be doing the same thing
it changes everything it changes your
physiology it changes your perspective
and why i think that's so powerful
particularly now more than ever stephen
like we
seemingly we're in a very divided and
toxic world
right seemingly
what we need is more compassion
right but how do you get compassion we
can't just say
you know i want to be more compassionate
that can work for some people use this
right
make them a hero
ask say to yourself if i were them i'd
be doing the same thing
you know it really helps humanity it
helps you feel better individually but
it will help connect you with people
around you people who've got different
views and perspectives it allows you to
sit alongside them so this is probably
one of the things that i use the most
along with which sort of goes along with
this
um
and this is sort of the big heading in
chapter 5 of the book it's called seek
out friction
right look this is when you become a
master of your own happiness
right
the whole goal of my work at the moment
is to
i don't want
people to be dependent on the actions of
other people for them to be happy right
if you constantly getting triggered and
and frustrated by the tone of your
colleagues emails or the way that your
partner is talking to you right
if you're waiting for them to change in
order for you to be happy
well you could be waiting a long time if
we go back to my core happiness stool
you've lost control you have no control
because you're dependent on other people
so
i
talk about this as social friction
right just as in in the gym you know you
can do physical friction you can push up
you can press up against your body and
you get stronger i'm saying you can
press up against other people and also
get stronger so every time you get
triggered i actually do this i do this
every single day
let's say let's say social media
let's say you get a negative comment
let's say i get negative comments
in the past five years ago when i you
know was first on bbc one about seven
years ago now actually
um i would have got triggered got so
frustrated i would have felt really bad
what's going on why is this happening
you know all i'm trying to do is help
people would have created this narrative
now
it's like ah
why is this triggering me
is there some truth to it that i can
learn from
or is it because the other person's
having a bad day and they're taking it
out on me
and you become a master if you practice
this every day right because what
happens is that you take control over
your inner
thoughts you take control of your own
happiness because it's like okay it
doesn't matter you're being given
opportunities every day to learn
something
for me i can i can speak but i know this
to be true for most people
it's because it's it's pressed on one of
your insecurities
right when you get truly secure in who
you are
what other people say
it doesn't affect you like i've noticed
this in my own life right
we started off the conversation talking
about external validation
like the problem when you need external
validation for your self-worth
is that when you get it you feel great
or you think you feel great
it's a very fragile uh way of feeling
great but when you get criticism you go
to the other extreme where you feel
worthless and you turn to whatever your
junk happiness habit is instagram
gambling drink porn whatever it is right
you turn to that as a way of
compensating but when you do the work
when you look for social friction
and you allow it to become your teacher
you start to process your insecurities
and then if people praise me now on
social media say oh wrong in that
podcast changed my life or you know your
book has really had an impact on me and
my mental well-being
i
like hearing that
but it doesn't artificially elevate my
ego like it might have done a few years
ago but at the same time if i get
criticism
right if i get criticism it doesn't drag
me down to those depths either i can i'm
just a lot more level
did that make sense
100
as you were saying that once again my
mind
sat there and thought how does he know
all of this stuff and how has he gotten
to a place where he can be so empathetic
and he can understand others to the
point that you can as you say make them
a hero and practice that what seems like
a pretty radical form of empathy in
situations where others would resort to
blame and um you know antagonism and
attacking others and it appears to me
that is because you've understood
yourself and actually being able to see
the you know what people might describe
as the insecurities or the flaws in
others or the triggers and others
is only possible once you've understood
yourself and it's funny because when i
put certain things on instagram i know
that i'm going to get backlash so if i
say
personal responsibility is really
important you can choose for example in
the case of what you've said there you
can choose to make someone else a hero
if someone cuts you off it's a choice
um as to whether you're you're happy or
you're triggered i know
there's a small proportion of people who
will slide into my dms and go you're
wrong if they've cut me off that's
forced me to be unhappy or i'm not at
fault for being unhappy right
and it tends to be the case that those
that are able to make that person a hero
or to practice empathy are those that
have actually done the work to
understand why
they are triggered why they were
insecure and why they react in the way
they do so again it feels to me that
this really underlying foundational
piece of work that is the catalyst for
being able to do all of these amazing
things that you've written about and
that you understand again is that like
that awareness as you described it
yeah i think he's spot on stephen
it also comes from
having lived through the mental turmoil
of
taking a different path of
blaming others
and seeing yourself as a victim and
often we absorb these sort of patterns
from our parents right
i can see clearly now how mum and dad
would react to the world and i could see
how i absorbed a lot of that and i
thought that's how you show up with the
world
but we can all choose to approach the
world differently
just because you have approached the
world a certain way
for all the years you've been on this
planet let's say until this conversation
right
everyone listening or watching has a
choice at the end of this conversation
they can decide whether to act on
something they've heard
or not
can i just press you on that one on that
point there about your parents because i
think it's it touched on something that
i really relate to in my
in one of my parents which is um
and this might be an immigrant thing my
mom was pretty badly racially abused for
for you know living in plymouth she's a
nigerian woman you know i really didn't
see anyone else in my in my city that
looked like her if i'm honest once upon
a you know once in a while i might once
a year but she was an anomaly in
appearance she was a nigerian woman with
long you know nigerian hair
um
and i grew up i have to say because she
was often racially abused
seeing a kind of bias in her towards
thinking that
the world was out to get her
and
um
i don't think that served her if i'm
gonna be completely honest if you know
what i mean there that and you see in
other people that kind of sense that
they are a victim
do i ever
you know
i would say this is how
my mum
very much has shown up with the world
and
similar stories you know there is all
kinds of reasons for that
and you absorb that you think that's the
way you know that's what your parents
how they react it's often what you
absorb as a child you think that's the
way so i can't believe they did that
they they did that differently
i would feel differently
and
it's really understanding that you have
a choice
in how you show the world you have a
choice in how you feel about a situation
you can
choose a different story mum to be fair
to my mum's now 81 she's pretty immobile
uh me or my brother give her breakfast
on most days um
she is changing
right she it's so wonderful to see
sometimes it's like
well done mum like
you're not it's just so wonderful to see
that
any one of us can change
at any age right we can make subtle
choices small things that make a big
difference you know i also grew up very
protective you know
you'd see things that weren't there you
know man if someone cut me up in my 20s
i'm not sure i should even
say what went through my mind right
you know i wasn't calm and content
you know at all i'd get triggered
i think they were
you know whatever you know i may even
shout in my car
you know
uh for the sake of my career should
probably just not go any further but i'm
just joking you know i'm saying i
probably said things in my head
or scream them out that i'm not
particularly proud of now
but i can see that i didn't have the
emotional maturity
and the emotional awareness
to do anything different
what is that what is that that vic is
victimhood in your view often like an
ill thought through form of self-defense
that because i'm thinking about why say
our per se our mothers who are subject
to a lot of abuse or whatever why did
they make the choice that the world was
not on their side and how because that
seems like maybe in the
the short term it might help you so if
something happens to you or you know
you know you're unsuccessful in business
um you can say well it was the bank
they're racist
um how how what is the cycle the
psychology there and the human that's
choosing to default to victimhood and
you see it in a lot of my i see it a lot
of my friends actually when they fail at
something it appears that they use they
use blame as a way to protect their
self-esteem or i think you just nailed
it that that's what it is it's
protection it's it's to give you that
feeling of safety that's what we're
always craving we want to feel safe so
it makes you feel safe actually it's not
it's not me
it's out there it's not in here it's out
there that's the problem if that changed
i think that's part of it
so but is that because those people
can't
they could they can't deal with more
that they're too they're too fragile
that they can't deal with more
what they perceive to be
evidence of their inadequacy
yeah
absolutely and it also comes down to
any trauma
that they may be carrying from their
childhoods this is the other thing i've
learned stephen is that
you know without going to details on mum
and dads um that i don't have permission
to share you know there were traumatic
things that happened early on in mum's
life
and so now i can look at that with
a deep level of compassion that oh
that's why
mum behaves the way she does because
actually she got programmed at a young
age
that i have to be a certain way
right and then you you pass it on and i
think you said about your mum and my mum
let me share something from from my life
that maybe just fits in there a little
bit which is
we create these behavioral patterns
usually in childhood
right because we want the love and
affection of our parents we want the
validation because they're our
caregivers right we need that to feel
safe
so
touching what we said earlier
i knew that if i came out with 100
there'd be smiles at home right
everyone's happy wrong is done well
right
so
i internalize that i think that's the
way to be loved in life
fast forward i'm at university and
there's a passion here in all aspects of
life
um
like
whether i was
seven and if i lost at ludo
my mum says i would literally toss the
board up and storm out the room like i
was furious if i lost at ludo
right and it sounds like a funny thing
that your mum embarrasses you with from
thailand no actually now that i've
unpicked it it's actually very serious
i remember i was at uni
maybe second third fourth year at uni
can't remember on a sunday often after
the passing of the friday and saturday
night we'd end up in diane's pool hall
in edinburgh i go with one of my mates
and i'm a pretty decent pool sneaker
player right
if i was ever losing
i'd go into the
toilets and look at myself in the mirror
give myself a talking to you i'll tell
these guys have a little slap on the
face come back out
more often than not i would go on and
then win the match
and i thought i just liked winning and i
was competitive
that was all the story complete nonsense
it wasn't that i liked winning
it was that the pain of losing
was too great because it
it reminds me on a deep primal level
i'm not loved when i lose when i'm not
the best
right so it's that feeling of safety
and here's the other thing
if i did win i wasn't happy that one i
was just happy that i didn't lose
right and then you compensate you don't
realize it it might be a bit more sugar
that evening a few extra beers that
night
a little cheeky trip to the casino on
the way back because you've got this
discomfort
in your body in your soul
right that you need
something you need a junk happiness
habit
to deal with it
we're all going through that
my parents your parents right
they've
they've also had childhood programming
that they're playing at
and i think when we really get that we
can be compassionate
i have to say that was
just outstandingly beautiful the way
you've articulated all of that and it
really did bring me back to this sense
of empathy which links to something you
said earlier which is if i'd gone
through what my mum had gone through
coming from africa
to the uk
you know god knows what age she did i
think maybe 17 having left school and
then having to fight for survival in the
way that my mum did and i what you know
my mum is the single hardest working
person i've ever met my entire life
i would have behaved in the exact same
way yeah and that really it does a
remarkable thing for
your perspective on them
how you know how you view their struggle
and how you view their current behavior
which i think is actually a really good
pathway to engaging with them and then
being able to have conversations and
that's it is such a beautiful sentence
that one of had i been through what
they've been through i would have
behaved in the exact same way and that
is completely true of my mother i did
not
i did not have to struggle in the way
she did because of her struggle
it's true for all of us actually
i think we can all apply that
to every single interaction in our life
and in fact my challenge would be try it
suck it and see see what life
feels like see what your
experience of life
physically viscerally emotionally see
what it feels like when you start to
show up like that day to day
right if you're skeptical okay i hate
your skepticism
my challenge to you if you're skeptical
is try for three days
just try it
because i'm not here to try and convince
people i'm not here to tell people what
to do
i know this has literally transformed
the way i show up with the worlds and
try it with your enemies
right yeah sure try it with your parents
who hopefully you love
trap with your enemies try it with that
person at work
you don't like
try it with that boss
who really pisses you off and
riles you up every time
try it maybe you can't do that straight
away maybe we have to work up to that
this is a skill
right happiness is a skill you can get
better at it but how would you know how
to get better at it when did you get
taught the skill of happiness
i didn't get taught it right i don't
teach it at school
i didn't teach at university i didn't
learn it from my parents i didn't learn
it from society in fact the lessons i
learned from society were that you need
to earn more money you need to get a
better job you need to get a nicer car
nicer holiday those things are signs of
success and therefore happiness
and it's a myth i think that's the
biggest myth we fall for we think that's
what happiness says
success is success happiness is
happiness they can sometimes coincide
but they don't always
but they can do if you back up if you
take a pause you start to do some of the
things that we're talking about you
start to have a bit of time
to reflect
you know
solitude stephen is so important
right every bit of our free time now is
sucked up
like i went to this gorgeous coffee shop
next to your studio just before i came
in right
now i imagine
15 years ago you go into any coffee shop
in london you'd be standing in the queue
you'd be waiting
you know there might be five people in
front of you fine you'll be looking
around you'll be you might bump into
someone you know
you might be daydreaming
now what happens if you go into any
coffee shop
everyone's head down stuck in their
phone
right you're looking you're trying to
catch up with your emails just have a
quick cheeky look on instagram
i'm not criticizing anyone for doing
that but that comes at a cost it means
these little micro moments of downtime
where your brain is trying to solve
problems for you and process life
they're being lost if you're constantly
consuming
right if you're constantly consuming
content from outside whatever it is
even good content
right even
nourishing content if you're constantly
consuming you're not allowing your own
thoughts and emotions to come up
you know every summer now i take a
social media break i tried it two years
ago for the first i think three years
ago for the first time i took a few days
to really get into it then after two
weeks i didn't want to go back on now
i'm not anti-social media right i can
see the value that it has i use it to
try and spread helpful messaging as you
do
but i felt really good and what what i
really experienced even as i allowed
these deep innermost feelings to come
out i started to figure out what i think
what i think not what the world thinks
because that's half the problem going
back to what you said that person who's
confused
right it doesn't know where to start
here's another tip for them
see if you can have 10 minutes a day
without your phone
without music on right without an app
that you're looking at without
distraction just sit
maybe with a journal if you want but
just see what comes up
because often we're so scared of what's
going to come up we distract
and i would say you know for me a daily
practice of solitude for me typically
it's first thing in the morning
is so needed right the way i describe it
to people
it's like an early warning system
right so when i was a junior doctor in
edinburgh i remember being taught
when you're looking after sick patients
if you do regular
what we call obs so heart rate
respiratory rates um
you know temperature
depending on what parameters they fit
into
we could detect
several hours beforehand who was going
to end up needing high dependency beds
or intensive care it was like it was
really simple concept that by doing
these regular checks we can then take a
verse of action and make sure that
person doesn't end up going downhill and
i see my daily practice of solitude
as my early warning system
like it allows me to see what's coming
up right i know for years stephen i say
i know i know now but i didn't know then
when
my stress load was going up work family
pressure i'd feel this real tightness to
my right upper back but i was so busy i
didn't even notice it now i notice i
know
if in the morning when i'm doing my
solitude practice i feel that i'm like
oh
okay
there's stuff going on right what is
there is it work is it emotional and it
allows me
to intentionally say okay do i need to
cut out some commitments i've got do i
need to have a conversation with my wife
about something that's been bothering me
and i haven't said anything yet
everything i recommend steven is simple
i don't think anything i've suggested
so far costs any money at all
none of them actually take that much
time i'm really really passionate about
making sure this information is
accessible to everyone i've worked in
affluent areas i've worked in some very
very deprived areas
right and actually we're all
of course there are different pressures
but actually we're all having the same
universal human experience the same
ingredients are there in all of us that
when we apply them they make our lives
better no matter where we are
right someone when i was working in
order
right
an area of low socioeconomic status a
lot of my patients want benefits very
poor income
levels you know you would say a very you
know struggling area financially i can't
take away their poverty and their stress
from life
but if i can help them have 10 minutes
of themselves each morning
and do some breathing practices or even
write in a journal what they're feeling
that is going to lower their stress load
and that means they're going to be
better able to show up in their life and
deal with their stresses right so when
people say oh health happiness it's the
preserve of the middle classes and the
wealthy i disagree i absolutely disagree
and i'm so passionate to get that
message across health and happiness
can be accessible to everyone yes
it can be challenging for some people no
question there could be lots that you
want to change there'll be lots that you
ideally would wish it wasn't the way it
is
but you can
choose
your response to every single one of
those things you absolutely can and when
you learn to do that
that's freedom you know what's the
victor frankel quote in between stimulus
and response is a space
in that space lies your power to choose
your response and with your response
lies your growth and your freedom
one of the things you touched on there
which was really is really foundational
to everything you went on to say was
this idea of a morning routine and um
you know when i do q and a's and stuff
like that on social media people will
always ask me steve what's your morning
routine my morning routine is pretty
shitty i'll be completely honest i would
never lie to anybody about that it's
really really shitty and it's
inconsistent and it's quite
it's unthinking so it's kind of being
dragged into the day
um you describe these the 3ms of a
really good morning routine what are
those three m's of a good morning
routine what can i do today how long is
it going to take me and what do you
believe a good morning routine contains
yeah it's a big picture of you here
i have a bias towards morning routines
because i have found in my own life
they've really really helped me
so let me just talk about stress for a
moment because this really plays into
why i think morning routines are so
important
i've got this concept of micro stress
doses and stress thresholds so
every one of us have got our own unique
personal stress threshold right that
depends on your life how you deal with
things and what's going on
and what we get to that threshold that's
when things start to go wrong that's
when we
um we snap at someone we have a fight
with our partner our net goes or our
back goes into spasm right that's when
you're at your threshold
right
so
i'm saying to people and i've i've
really found this to be true for pretty
much everyone
let's say you wake up
and you are far away from your threshold
you've had a good night's sleep right so
you're feeling you've been good
what's the average morning for a lot of
people these days okay let's say the
alarm goes off at 6 30 right so they're
in a deep sleep
alarm goes off jolts them out of that
sleep they have to get it okay that's
micro stress dose or msd number one okay
pick up the phone
oh man i'm just gonna put it on snooze
you know i need a bit more snooze put it
back
six minutes later it goes on again msd
number two
you need pick up your phone you get i'm
quick you're gonna check email
oh man there were these three emails i
didn't get back to yesterday oh man i
need to do that msd number three
um have a quick look on instagram
someone's left you a snarky comment msd
number four then you realize oh man i've
been in bed for 10 minutes i have to get
up get ready i've got a guest coming to
shoot a podcast with i'm not talking
about your life i'm just saying anyone's
life you are talking about mine right
and so here's the point at me ronan each
one of those things right is a micro
stress dose and each one of those is
getting you closer and closer to that
stress threshold the mistake we make
is that when something happens at three
o'clock in the afternoon
right when that email from your
colleague frustrates you
you think it was that email
but it wasn't the email it was the fact
that you've already acquired 20 micro
stress doses you're right at your
threshold you've got no capacity to deal
with it so that email now bothers you
so
what i suggest to people is
many people leave the house in the
morning having already accumulated about
15 micro stress doses so they're already
a lot closer to their threshold than
they would have otherwise mean which
means they've got less resilience they
won't take much for them to get
triggered right so why i think morning
routines can be so valuable is they can
reduce
how many micro stress doses you're
exposed to first thing in the morning so
you are going into your day
with much more headroom and much more
resilience
but i think they're also useful
if you're feeling quite stressed when
you wake up and anxious i think they
help almost undo the damage of
microstrategies and bring you back to
baseline
was that clear
perfectly clear so that's my kind of
overarching view on why they're so
important so for me i know
if i do that morning routine yes it
gives me perspective on my life it
allows me to reflect but it also
um feeds the control leg of the core
happiness stool
but it also means that i'm not exposing
myself to micro stressors in fact i'm
getting back to baseline or i'm going
into negative i'm actually giving myself
a lot more resilience and capability to
face the day so i was trying to simplify
things to people so i think a complete
morning route scene for me has got these
three m's
mindfulness movement
mindset
and that's how i orientate my own
morning routine so i started with
mindfulness
now i've been doing this for a few years
right and currently my morning routine
is about 30 minutes but that's because
i've created a life where i can do that
and it works for me and i get up silly
early that's also because my kids have
always been early wises and i know
if i don't get that time to myself
i'm just not as good a dad and i'm not
as good a husband so my bedtime has got
earlier and earlier so i can get
up earlier and earlier before my kids do
right so i start with mindfulness which
at the moment is a practice of breath
work and then meditation
then what i do i go to my kitchen and i
put coffee on now very particular with
how i do my coffee i weigh out 15 grams
in the french press i pour 250 grams of
water and i put a timer on for five
minutes
why is that important it's not it's the
way i like my coffee but the point is i
know for five minutes my coffee's gonna
brew so in those five minutes
i don't go on instagram i don't check my
email i do a workout in my kitchen in my
pajamas
right i'm in my pajamas i'm not to put
on any fancy gear
i might do a bodyweight workout i might
have a kettlebell kicking around
whatever i feel like i will do and then
i get the gorgeous rewards of a hot
fresh cup of organic coffee that i like
and i sit there and i'll read something
um positive like i've got a few books
kicking around in my living room i'll
just pick one that i'm drawn to i'd
probably read for about 10 minutes while
sipping coffee something that's not
negative that's uplifting
right so that's what it looks like for
me now sometimes my daughter is
currently nine she's got a sixth sense
that daddy's up and she creeps in with
me if she gets in with me
what two things i want to say about that
the old wrong good from a few years ago
we got frustrated man i kind of need i
want my own space you know why yeah you
know i should have got up earlier i
don't do that anymore i'm a lot more
compassionate to myself i use that i go
okay great okay great she's here okay
okay darling just sit here daddy's just
finishing off my meditation
and she said i think okay this is cool
like i don't need to look at it as a
problem this is life right
if we think life is gonna be great
when everything goes our way we're gonna
be waiting a long time so i embrace it
now go fantastic
and then i also think as a dad what
she's also now
seeing
daddy prioritizes his health he thinks
it's important to look after his mental
well-being every day i'm hoping that she
also absorbs some of these ideas as she
grows up but the mindset piece i don't
sit there and read if my daughter said
we instead do affirmations together so
there's really good research on
affirmations in terms of what they do
for us
just short positive powerful statement
so the one we do together is we just say
i'm happy i'm calm i'm stress free right
so the two of us sit there we hold hands
and we say that for a minute
at the end of it i feel brilliant she
feels amazing
no i get it some people hear that okay
that is cheesy as anything
and maybe it is but you know what
there's good research on it
undergraduate students who did
affirmations before their exam perform
better
right
you know how you program your mind
matters so that's what mine looks like
right it used to be about five ten
minutes now yeah i can do half an hour
right but i've also become aligned i've
now i go to bed earlier right and let's
not forget stephen you're at a different
stage in life to me right i'm in my
early 40s i'm happily married i've got
two young kids
right you're in your late 20s
right was i doing morning routines when
i was 29 no i wasn't it's like clue that
i text you at 2 a.m last night isn't it
yeah well i woke up i was like oh man
like i'm getting up to do my routine and
steve has just gone to bed
but
but
let me tell you about a patient who i
saw
many years ago
i can't remember how old she was she's
probably around 42
really bad skin and i strongly felt that
stress was
exacerbating and really aggravating her
skin
and she said that's actually i don't
have time for any of this stuff right
i'm busy
i've got two kids i've got to get out to
work
and we try and make various things but
i managed to persuade her and inspire
her to try a five minute routine and
this is what she did she did the three
m's in five minutes it's just one minute
of what i call three four five breathing
right so you breathe in for three
you hold for four and you breathe out
for five any time your out breath is
longer than your in-breath you help to
lower your body's stress response and
activate its relaxation response okay
there's many ways you can do that but i
like this breath that i call the three
four five breaths so she did one minute
three four five breathing
she did two minutes of yoga
right she had some of her favorite
sequencing two minutes of yoga
and then she did two minutes of
affirmations
that's it and she got on with the day
she came to see me a few weeks later
and she thought she actually i just feel
so much better and her skin complaints
had gone down by over 50 and over the
course of the next few months she was
hardly getting any flare-ups at all
because it was a ripple effect it wasn't
just that
but by doing that and giving her that
little bubble of resilience first thing
in the morning
she would then go out for a walk at
lunch time instead of just sitting in
the canteen on her phone she'd go i'm
gonna go for ten minute walk around the
block you know it so for me it's just
you showing yourself right at the start
of the day
you know what i'm worth it i'm worth
spending a bit of time on today
and for me i'm a i've got a bias there
because if i don't do stuff like that in
the morning
i don't do it once the day starts forget
it and it's something that might have
value for your audience steven and i you
know i guess i'm coming and thinking
steven bartlett successful businessman
loads of entrepreneurs listening
um
thinking about you know business and
stuff and i'm i you know i i kind of
want to help people and
let's let's zoom into the middle and
movement
why is it that i'm able to do a five
minute workout every day like i've
really missed a day for three years
that's not because
i've got more motivation than anyone
else it's because i understand
the science of behavior change
right i think it's gonna i hope it's
gonna have value for people
there's two
big rules i've learned about human
behavior number one is
if you make something easy
you will do it
so
what's that got to do with my morning
routine well i made it so easy for me to
do right i don't need to buy any
equipment everything's there i don't
need to get changed i don't need to look
up a workout i don't need to do it's it
literally happens because
i don't have to think i've made it
really easy and to zoom this out to
business for a moment
it's reported that when amazon went to
one click ordering it's reported their
profits went up by 300 million dollars a
year
right so let's rewind 10 years when they
didn't have it what did you have to do
put in your order go to the next screen
you know type in your card deals go to
the next screen confirm audit right
every single step is a reason to
procrastinate pull out and not make the
purchase so what do they do one click
ordering boom before you blinked
something's coming that evening right so
they're doing what i think they should
do for their business why do netflix
roll one video or one show into the next
one
it's not out of the goodness of their
own hearts to go oh you know let's help
people
no they're using the science of human
behavior before you realize it's
12 30 at night
i need to go to bed i've got to get it
for work you are straight into another
episode so you don't stop that's why
youtube roll and see the next video
right so these guys understand human
behavior when we as humans try and apply
it to our own health we throw it out the
window we think it's got to be hard it's
got to be really tough i've got to go
running one hour four times a week
and we we again first two weeks in
january we managed to do it then we fall
off the wagon because we think
motivation is going to last forever and
it doesn't and the science is called the
motivation wave motivation comes up
motivation goes down
plan your behaviors for when your
motivation is down not when it's up then
you will still do it so number one is
you make it easy i've made it easy
number two
which is just as important as where are
you gonna put this behavior you can't
just think about it oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna meditate i'm gonna move no you
need to be very intentional
now every single behavior we do needs a
trigger
right so
a trigger could be oh i remember to do
it
sure that works it's just the most
unreliable trigger that exists the next
best trigger is like um a notification
like uh you know oh you've got to be
here to record a podcast with stephen
okay great i know i've got to do that or
you put a post-it note on your fridge
that's great but the very best trigger
as evidenced by the research and a lot
of this comes from professor bj fogg at
stanford instagram was literally
invented in his class as an assignment
essentially
he has shown that
if you stick on your new behavior onto
an existing habit
it's much more likely to happen
like the coffee like the coffee i don't
need my pa to phone me at five in the
morning say hey rongan listen
uh you must remember to make your coffee
i don't need my google calendar
notification to pop say hey wrong don't
don't forget
to make your coffee
i'm gonna do that it's locked in as a
habit i don't have to give it any
conscience but it's going to happen so
therefore if i stick my workout on there
i vastly increase the likelihood then
it's going to happen add on to the fact
that i keep kettlebells and dumbbells in
my kitchen my wife used to say can we
not just put these away in the cupboard
and i said listen babe here's the thing
and i've seen this with patients if you
put this stuff out of the way so that
the kitchen looks nice right
i'm never gonna lift up that weight
out of sight out of mind we need to
constantly trigger so
the kitchen's not a mess it's just in
the corner there's a kettlebell so as
i'm making the coffee i can see it it's
looking at me
even if all i do is pick it up to move
it i've picked it up and what it does
steven is that on a very on a very base
primal level it shows me each morning
that i have value that i'm worth
treating with respect you know chapter
three the book is all about treat
yourself with respect many of us um
as i've done for much of my life
don't we struggle with compassion for
ourselves we struggle to be kind to
ourselves
right but the research is really clear
people who are more compassionate to
themselves
they're healthier they're happier
they're more successful at work we think
we think we've got to beat ourselves up
inside to do stuff
right it's a myth it's a short term when
it's a long-term fail and there are
simple things that we can do
quick one as we all know energy
independence and living a little greener
has never been more important for a
better future it's a journey i've been
on over the last couple of years that
i've shared with you sporadically ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and there's a
lot of people out there that listen to
this podcast that are looking to make
that sustainable switch in the things
that run their daily life whether it's
their home their car their vehicles
whatever it might be so when a good
friend of mine at a company called my
energy called jordan told me she was
interested in sponsoring this podcast i
jumped at the opportunity so for those
of you that don't know my energy are a
uk renewable energy brand whose mission
is to increase the usage of green energy
helping people like you and i to save
time and money when it comes to making
sustainable switches in our lives so if
this resonates with you and you're the
type of person that's been looking or
thinking about going on your own
sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at my
myenergy.com
a lot of people when they talk about
health and happiness in those topics you
know they tend to focus on things like
what we eat
you know that seems to be a really big
um
factor in
health one of the things we've talked
about there that i also read about in
your in your work is you would actually
suggest that maybe the most foundational
thing to all of our lives and it's kind
of clearly one of the things that i've
i've not been so consistent with is
sleep
so why is sleep so foundational and so
so important i actually read that you
said if there was one sort of health
recommendation you would make to
everybody it would be to try and get
more sleep why do you prioritize that so
highly why is that so important
i think the reason why sleep is so
important for society at the moment is
because of how much we've lost
so depending on which study you read
you'll have a slightly different
results but essentially compared to
about
60 years ago
you know we may have lost up to 25 of
our sleep
right so on an eight hour
sleep cycle we may have lost
you know two hours of sleep
right now when you think about what
sleep does
for the body and the brain and the mind
you'd be like well actually that is
gonna have a consequence so in the short
term we all know what does that feel
like when we haven't slept well okay do
we feel like our best selves
no we're a bit irritable we're a bit
moody what
are we like with those close to us when
we haven't slept well are we
patient
and calm are we a bit ratty a bit angsty
what do you crave when you haven't slept
well you don't crave
fruit and vegetables and whole foods you
crave sugar and cakes and candy right
because your hormones change when you
haven't slept properly right you're less
able to resist temptation when you
haven't slept
right you're much more likely to get
emotionally triggered when you haven't
slept
so sleep is really really important in
the short term but in the long term
sleep deprivation is associated with
pretty much every single chronic disease
we have
heart disease alzheimer's
um autoimmune disease
all these things now we're pretty sure
are directly not just associated with
sleep deprivation is thought to be
causative
right so this is why we think i'm just
going to crush it in my 20s 30s
you know i'll sleep when i'm dead i'll
sleep later i get there are phases in
our life where we have to probably work
harder than we would ideally do
we we get opportunities we have to take
it we feel we have to take advantage of
them
fine i get that i'm not saying you're
gonna
sleep seven to eight hours every single
night i don't manage to and i do
prioritize my sleep
but by and large
the biggest problem we have with sleep
is that we don't prioritize it we've
never lived in a society where there are
this many distractions
from sleep a million years ago you
didn't have you know what you do it gets
dark you have a campfire you sit around
and chat
and then
yeah you could go off to bed aren't you
it's so true we live as if sleep is the
the only optional thing it's the thing
that can we could do one hour two hours
three hours but
we then over prioritize but i can't miss
that appointment i can't miss that work
commitment but the sleep can come and go
it's optional yeah and it's and i get
the temptation there's always something
you could do you could watch a youtube
video you could watch a new boss series
you know i understand that there are
distractions
i totally get that
but
if you are struggling in life if you
can't focus as much as you want to at
work if you've tried going on diets
before and you can't stick to eating the
right kinds of foods that you're trying
to choose
you may be better off
focusing on your sleep i've helped
people lose weight i've helped people
improve so many aspects of their health
by not changing their diet and i'm a big
proponent of whole food-based diets
right
but i've gone what's the lever i need to
turn here
not what can i lecture the patient about
what is the lever i need to turn here so
i talk about these four pillars of
health certainly for physical health
food movement sleep and relaxation
and when my first book came out talking
about this about five years ago people
say doctor where should i start
and i said well look
we're all different
ask yourself this question ask yourself
which of these four pillars
do i need the most help with
because we all kind of intuitively know
for me it's probably stress
like my diet movement's pretty good i'm
pretty good in my sleep but if i could
do more to manage stress that would have
a huge impact on my health but we don't
do that we go to our favorite bit right
so people who've already pretty good
with their diet they try and make it
five percent better negating the fact
that they're only sleeping four and a
half hours every night
but go to your weakest link make a small
change there i'm not talking about seven
eight hours if you can even sleep for 15
minutes more a night
you will have a noticeable and
measurable impact on your physiology and
the way that you feel
and the other thing we're now learning
about um sleep particularly i think it's
the rem the rem phase of sleep
is this what sleep researchers are
calling emotional first aid
why it allows you to
process and
you know kind of regulate emotions and
memories
so we are living in this time of the
mental health epidemic i'm very
concerned over what the impact of the
last couple years is going to have
on people's mental well-being
but a lot of people don't realize that
sleep
when you sleep
more when you sleep of better quality
you actually do emotional first aid you
actually are better at processing
emotions your relationships will be
better your mood will be better when you
slept more so
the number one thing we don't do is
prioritize it so for most people if all
they do is prioritize it
that would be a big start and then i
always think i need to say when i'm
talking about sleep i don't want to
stress people out because some people
may hear that stephen and go
um i know i'm stressed out right i've
heard what you just said sleep's gonna
do or i've got a young child i can't
sleep through the night that's okay we
all have phases like that this is day in
day out over a period of years i'm
talking about it as a chronic disease
but there are small things that you can
do
right getting outside in the morning for
even 10 minutes and seeing natural light
that will help you sleep better at night
that is free it is accessible to
everyone right
why
if you think about what i said about a
million years ago we've we have evolved
as humans to have a big differential
between our maximum light exposure and
our minimum light exposure right so
typically in the day we'd be outside and
at night time would be completely dark
right so so light is measured in a unit
of light called lux
right
completely dark room zero lux
if you go outside on a cloudy day
in the uk overcast cloudy day for 10 or
15 minutes you're going to get about 10
000 looks through your eyes
go back on a sunny day you're going to
get about 20 or 30 000 likes through
your eyes
go into the most brightly lit office
building in the uk
you're probably going to get between 500
and 700 lux it's not much even on a
cloudy day
you're getting so much more than you
would get inside so for some people
all they have to do is get outside in
the morning for 10 minutes or even at
lunch time go for a walk outside for 10
minutes that will help set what's called
your circadian rhythm which helps you
sleep better at night so that's a simple
one caffeine's a big one right you know
i love coffee
but i don't drink it after midday
right i'll drink it in the morning i
won't drink it after midday
there are genetic differences between
different people and how we process it
for sure
but you know by and large half life is
six hours so that means if you have a
large coffee
at
midday
at 6 p.m half of that caffeine is going
around your brain and it could be at
midnight a quarter could still be going
around your brain
so this is not about lecturing this is
about
hopefully empowering people to go oh
maybe that 3pm coffee i take to get me
through the afternoon
oh maybe that's why i can't sleep well
and then i'm even more tired the next
day and i'm stuck in this vicious cycle
where i need the caffeine to keep
getting me through and again if
someone's listening to this and they're
not sure
i would say okay
why not try for seven days
only having caffeine in the morning and
just see what happens observe do you
feel better
does it help do you have more energy
great and if you think you're somewhere
and you really think it's a problem you
might want to wean down and try seven
days without
i never tell my patient to stop drinking
coffee
or to stop drinking alcohol i want to
help show them the impact it's having
right so let's say a patient's um
drinking too much alcohol for their
health
i want to help persuade them to go for
seven days without and see how they feel
right
if they can experience how they feel
differently
and then they go yeah i love it but you
know what the amount of fun i get on a
friday night hanging out with my mates
having a few beers it's worth the
hangover and the fatigue and the
irritability on saturday
if they say that they're happy with that
trade-off okay
fine
but a lot of people are not aware of the
trade-off like with coffee a lot we are
drinking so much we are a nation of
caffeine addicts we're a world of
caffeine addicts frankly it's a
psychoactive stimulants
it's a beautiful one but it's a
psychoactive stimulant so i'm all i'm
saying is if you're struggling with your
sleep
you know you might want to reduce it you
might want to knock it back a bit and
there's plenty more we could talk about
with sleep but all i want to say to
people is
small changes to your sleep make a
difference don't set the goal that's
going to be eight hours a night sure if
you can do that wonderful but even 15
minutes more a day will absolutely make
a difference
one of the moments in your book that you
describe as being really pivotal
and you've referenced early as being
pivotal to your life was the moment your
child got ill
um your six month old child became
unwell and the kind of
that became a catalyst
in your life for
i guess
many things can you talk to me about why
that was so um pivotal and
and and why when your child became ill
you you know
that was in part what i understand is
part of the inspiration behind many of
the thoughts in the book
my son jainam um
getting sick at six months old
literally
changed the course of my career
but i wouldn't be doing what i'm doing
today had that not happened
so rewind 2010
i become a father for the first time
right super excited right it's amazing
we're new parents everything's going
well bloody blahdy blah and that
december
um the end of december we were we
decided to go on holiday for a week in
france
i've got friends out there one of them's
got a house out there we were going to
go and stay there
and we flew out just after christmas my
wife myself and my son
and we got to my friend's house they
weren't going to be there on the next
day
and we meant to sleep downstairs there
that was the room that we'd been
allocated at my friend's place
and normally my wife would have probably
gone and put him
to sleep but she said she didn't feel
she wanted to he was a bit sniffly he
wasn't um
[Music]
you know she mother's intuition called
whatever you will she didn't do it
anyway we're we're upstairs in this kind
of open plank kitchen i think i'm doing
some washing up and then she calls out
to me he says wrong and he's not moving
i drop everything turn around
see him
and um
i think he's probably choking because
he's had a lot of phlegm all day so i
take him turn him over i try and clear
his airway
nothing's happening
uh i probably froze i can't quite
remember now with clarity but my said
look we just got to get into the
hospital so we got to the hospital which
is two minutes away
we got in
and you could see how scared the uh
medics were because it's not uncommon
for children at the age of six months to
have a convulsion it's something we call
a febrile convulsion there's a fever
that causes the convulsion
but he had no fever they were like well
why on earth is a six-month-old kid
just stopped moving and had a convulsion
so he got blue lighted down there
because it was a little mountain resort
down to the valley my wife's going in
the ambulance i'm like following in the
car thing what on earth is happening we
get there
you know he's motionless we're super
scared we thought we might lose him that
night he had two lumbar punctures he had
all kinds of blood tests then it turns
out later that he had very low levels of
calcium in his blood which is why he had
a convulsion
like well why has that happened and i
said look we're still waiting for more
tests a few hours later it comes back
he's got no vitamin d in his body well
very low levels of vitamin d
that's why his calcium drops
thankfully he got a calcium infusion he
got vitamin d
five days later you know we get
discharged
but why did that have such a big impact
on me well hey of course i nearly my son
nearly died
but i
thought i'd let him down
that's the truth demon
i thought my my son has nearly died from
a preventable vitamin deficiency
i've gone to one of europe's most
prestigious medical schools edinburgh
i've got an immunology degree i've done
my specialist exams done my general
practice exams with all my so-called
qualifications
i was unable to prevent my son from
getting sick so i took it personally as
if i had messed up and actually weirdly
enough a few weeks before that i'd
become aware of vitamin d i'd gone i
remember thinking shouldn't my son be on
vitamin d this was years ago i remember
phoning my wife from work said hey can
you go and take him to the doctor we're
told as doctors not to make medical
decisions for our own family it's not
deemed good practice i sent her a
protocol to just show that to the doctor
say your husband's a gp you know he's
just thinking about
about this and the gp just laughed her
out said you could have just printed you
could just type this up on word this is
nonsense he doesn't need anything
anyway two weeks later he's in france
convulsion nearly dies
why does that have such a big impact on
me why has it had such a big impact on
me
because
i thought i'd failed
right my whole
identity is is around being perfect at
that point
so i want perfection in every aspect of
my life oh i wanted perfectionary
aspects of my life and of course my
darling son
i thought so guilty stephen i became
obsessed right modern medicine saved his
life
but
that's it modern medicine often stops at
that point i i was asking him well what
happens if he's not had victim and d in
a system
for the last few months which he didn't
vitamin d is critical for our immune
system it's critical could this be why
he's got eczema could this be
contributing fast there's a look he's
he's fine now and i thought this is not
good enough for me
so i made it my mission
i said to myself internally i don't
think i ever verbalized it out
i said i am going to get my son back to
full health as if this had never
happened
i became obsessed i'd read up about
vitamin d that led me to the gut
microbiome that led me to all kinds of
stuff that i never learned at medical
school that i've used to help him he is
a thriving happy healthy strong 11 year
old boy
okay
the principles and the tools that i've
learned are what i've been using with my
patients for years it's what i used on
doctor in the house on bbc one to show
people
all around the country and it's gone to
70 countries around the world that all
kinds of conditions type 2 diabetes
fibromyalgia panic attacks anxiety
irritable bowel syndrome can all be
either
reversed or significantly improved by
making small changes to our lifestyle
that
moment
drove me to learn all this stuff which i
now share
and help
you know arguing millions of people now
and
for years
i wished
it didn't happen
but i've i've changed my view
for two reasons one reason was
that guilt i felt stephen i carried in
as a dad
he doesn't need his dad feeling guilty
that doesn't make me a calm present
attentive father
that brings baggage into the
relationship and i i could see that
well i i'd like to think particularly
these days i've got a high degree of
self-awareness i could see that see
wrong this is guilt it's not his fault
he doesn't need a guilty dad so that was
a stimulus to go inward and figure some
of this stuff out to figure out where
does this come from but it all plays in
stephen or you know as we talk you can
see the theme
in the start of our conversation in the
middle now talking about my son
i have expected perfection of myself in
everything i've ever
done right that's been my identity with
my son i felt as though i let him down
now i've let go of pretty much all of
that
it
i say pretty much because it still pops
in so in my role as a father i think i
do a good job they're kind considerate
kids they're happy
but could i do a better job probably i'm
not going to beat myself up on that
anymore
but i want to work on that so
now i look back and i've now told myself
a different story
right this is true you can tell me if
you think it's true
i now think that was meant to happen
that happened so that daddy could learn
all of the
um tools that i've learned to help him
and now help
thousands of people
hundreds of thousands you know as i say
arguing millions
i wouldn't have had those learnings had
it not happen now when i started
thinking like that i would think yeah
but
why did he have to go through that
in order for me to learn this but again
that's me putting a story what do you
mean go through it maybe he doesn't know
he's been through anything maybe that's
his life journey maybe he's going to
learn loads from that experience
do you know what i mean and that's the
perspective choice i guess you
you talked about earlier it's almost
like making an incident a negative
incident the hero of your own life as
opposed to be
you know
shrouding it with guilt and blame and
resentment so yeah it's choosing a
happiness story about it because
ultimately i can't change the reality of
what happened
whether i wanted it to or not of course
at that moment would i want it to happen
no of course not but now
given that it can't be changed given
that it is has happened and is now in
the past
how now to show up
in my everyday life and be happy be
content help people serve people serve
my children as a good father well it's
to let go of that and move on choose a
happiness story we can all do it it's
hard sometimes but it doesn't mean it's
not possible
and what is your mission now as you look
ahead to the future you've achieved so
much
across such a diverse
a range of pursuits you know everything
from your tv to podcast to books and
everything in between your work as a gp
your medical practice everything what is
your mission now as you look ahead to
your future
the mission that i have stated publicly
for the last few years has been over the
course of my career
i want to help 100 million people
live better lives
i want to help them with their health
and their happiness
but you know
over the last few months that's not been
sitting that well with me anymore
i mean i'm really good friends with my
videographer gareth who films every
podcast that i do
and we've been chatting a lot about it
and
you know when i first stated that
publicly for the first time i was so
scared well people think he's got a big
ego you know i did i didn't i didn't
want partly didn't want to share that i
thought
what will people think of me
right why that's been so good for me
is it's helped me
make decisions as you know
the amount of incoming into our inboxes
and what we could be doing is
vast
so the hundred millifigure allows me to
think
okay is this going to get me closer to
100 million or not so i think it's
served a really good role
i think missions can do at particular
moments in life but we don't need to be
stuck to them forever
so
you know that figure you know i thought
well five million people each week are
watching doctor in the house in bbc one
okay
that means
if only one percent of people watch that
and make a change in their life that's a
lot of people right and now that's gone
to 70 countries around the world i'm
like okay
so this is how you can use the media
to amplify your message and help people
with hopefully a strong simple message
all over the world
right now i think
and and that's helped me do things like
you know i'll be honest like when i
started my podcast
it was just a bit of fun right i didn't
have a name i didn't have a logo um i
just thought okay this would be cool i
didn't know what the name was when i was
interviewing people
like the first six interviews
but it's evolved into
you know like your show i guess like a
juggernaut show which has a huge
following that impacts the lives of
hundreds of thousands of people each
week
right so
the mission served me but it's not sure
like i don't have a new replacement one
at the moment but i almost think 100
million is limiting well why why a
hundred million right that's not said
with any level of arrogance it's just
like well
every human has
unlimited potential you know this is
what i always try and do i want every
person who reads my books or listens to
my podcast to feel that they can be the
architect of their own health and
happiness
that's not me
diminishing the fact that your
environment that society plays a role
no but even if it does
i still want that person to feel that
they have agency and they've got an
element of control so
if i think about short-term goals
you know i very much want this book to
be a success not so that it can feed my
ego but because i genuinely think the 10
chapters the 10 life lessons are
universal so whoever you are
wherever you are in life i think these
10 chapters these 10 lessons hold true
for everyone if anyone disagrees i'd
welcome a conversation about it but i
really think they do and i think they're
sort of things that people can revisit
they use them then in a few months when
life goes off track they can come back
that's one immediate goal
but i think
going beyond that
the mission's about conversation
right conversation matters
long-form conversation like what you do
on this show like what i do on my show
that matters we need that now more than
ever everything is reduced down to that
that that smallest sound bite that we
can get out there
the problem is that comes at a cost
because
we lose perspective it doesn't make us
compassionate it makes us angry
right people are isolated there's a lack
of community people feel lonely it's
driving them to junk happiness habits
i've got so many young men who've come
to see me who've got pornography
addiction right they can't even look me
in the eye when they tell me they're
that ashamed and embarrassed they've not
told anyone they've not taught their
friends they've not told their parents
there will be someone stephen
listening to this right now
who's got
an issue with pornography and they don't
know where to turn
picking up on that point of loneliness i
think in our society we view loneliness
as a sad thing
in the sense that when someone's lonely
it almost feels like it's a sign of
their inadequacy or they're like lack of
attraction or then they're not a
compelling human being they weren't able
to forge interactions so
although i i've now come to learn that
it's in fact a signal to get back to our
tribes
we have we don't treat it like other
signals we don't treat it like thirst we
don't treat it like hunger we will say
if we're thirsty or we're hungry
but we won't say if we're lonely because
it's stigmatized right um
i came to learn from the research i've
done and i saw similar stats which were
terrifying in your work
is that loneliness isn't a sad thing
it's actually a really dangerous thing
so can you speak to the the negative
consequence of loneliness
the way
society is set up now is making us
lonely
we've moved away from work we've moved
away from our families we don't have the
tribes around us and it's
very very damaging for our health
right some research suggests that the
feeling of being lonely is as harmful as
smoking 15 cigarettes per day one five
right
increases our risk of heart disease
strokes
you're more likely to die earlier
if you feel lonely why is that
right think about it a million years ago
you're with your tribe you're with your
community
right if a wild predator
is
approaching the tribe your stress
response kicks into gear that's a good
thing it's going to help you take action
to keep you safe
brilliant all kinds of things happen in
the body when that happens
loneliness is also a signal think back a
million years ago if you were out by
yourself
you don't have your tribe around you
your body is clever your body knows you
are
at risk you are vulnerable to attack so
it activates your stress response your
blood sugar goes up your blood pressure
goes up your blood becomes more prone to
clotting right you're amygdala your
emotional brain goes on to high alert so
you're hyper vigilant you become anxious
right all these things happen when you
feel lonely right you have physical
changes in your body
now loneliness is hard
if people are suffering i understand
right i really understand
but small things make a difference
you can start off by saying hi
to the barista at the coffee shop
right but maybe you've got a friend you
haven't spoken to in a while
maybe you've got busy with your life
they've got busy with their life give
them a call
right that's all it takes it's a ripple
effect start small and i promise you
will start to feel the difference
dr ronan i i have to i couldn't thank
you enough for the wisdom and for the
time that you've given me today it's
really really really special i sit here
sometimes with guests and i think
um you know i think you know they've
written a book and it's very nice and
everything but
having
experienced the way that you've um done
the self-work and having
had a taste of the way that you have
empathy
in your approach to causing behavioral
and lifestyle change to people i i feel
like this book is just critically
important you know
it's funny because i was thinking i'm
going to end this podcast by giving the
book a compliment but i don't think i
have to i think if people see who you
are today the wisdom the empathy the
experience the vulnerability
i think any person that is sound of mind
and that wants to improve their life
will know
that this book is critically important
to them that it is inclusive that is
that is relatable and that it will hold
their hand through change in a in a way
which is empathetic and that's that
those are my favorite books and i was
sat here and i'm going to be completely
honest because i don't [ __ ] people i
just don't say things i don't believe
them i was sat here thinking [ __ ] steve
because i've only been i've only i was
only given a small taste of the book by
your publisher
i
need to read this book and if that's the
impact you've had on me
i know it's going to be the impact
you've had on my my listeners so thank
you because you know that really really
is you know
understanding where we are in the world
in culture we need more books like this
we have a tradition on this podcast
which is the last guest writes a
question for the next guest and i don't
actually get to read on my mother's life
i don't read it until i open the book so
i've just opened the book and seen what
our last guest has written so my last
guest
wrote the question and i've not read it
yet so here we go
but he's got great handwriting so
what is something that people value
that you no longer value
an attachment to truth
i no longer
value
being right
i no longer value having to know the
right answer i no longer value
thinking
this is the truth and i'm gonna hold on
to this at all costs
and i think many people do
i now value curiosity and being the
learner
i just want to learn i want to explore
i'm happy for pre-existing assumptions
i've had in my life to be shown to be
incorrect
i'm not attached to being right i'm not
attached to being wrong
what i am attached to
is learning
and that's working for me at the moment
dr rongan thank you you are simply
amazing and you are really the gift that
keeps on giving so i can't wait to read
the book in its entirety
happy mind happy life 10 simple ways to
feel great every day thanks for having
me thanks i can't wait wait to read the
book in its entirety
happy mind happy life 10 simple ways to
feel great every day thanks for having
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you